As the general rule goes, you should never
bring a knife to a gun fight… unless of
course that knife happens to be an NRS-2,
a knife that also just so happens to have
a gun built into the handle.
Designed in early 1980s for Spetsnaz troops,
the NRS-2 is still used today by some members
of the Russian special forces.
The origins of this peculiar firearm can be
traced back to the 1970s when engineers working
at the Tula arms factory were tasked with
creating “a close combat weapon for army
reconnaissance units“. Under the oversight
of designer, R. D. Khlynin, an early precursor
to the NRS-2 known, interestingly enough,
as the NRS, was developed that made use of
the recently created SP-3 ammunition. These
are specialised “silenced” bullets that
had been developed during the Cold War period
especially for spies and special forces units
operating either covertly or behind enemy
lines.
Although noticeably weaker than conventional
bullets, SP-3 ammunition was considered to
be acceptably powerful for single shot weapons
like the MSP special compact pistol which
was also developed under the supervision of
Khlynin.
But the NRS wasn’t just a knife with a gun
in the handle, it also doubled as a screwdriver,
a saw and even had a tool built into the scabbard
that could cut through wires up to 5mm thick.
The scabbard was also insulated so that the
knife could be used to cut through live electric
cables, so long as the line wasn’t transmitting
more than 380 volts.
A few years later when SP-3 ammunition was
phased out in favour of the more powerful
and reliable SP-4 ammunition, the NRS was
redesigned by G. A. Savishcnev, I. P Shedlos,
and V. Ya. Ovchinnikov to make use of it.
Along with providing greater killing range,
the NRS-2 included a number of other notable
improvements such as an attachment for crimping
primer caps and a sharper tip more suited
for stabbing through thick cloth and thinly
armoured targets. This new and improved gun
knife officially went into service in 1986.
So how exactly does the NRS-2 work you ask?
Well, to put it simply, housed just inside
of the knife’s handle is a small gap, in
which an incredibly rudimentary firing mechanism
can be found. This mechanism can store one
round at a time and needs to be removed once
the round has been spent. The handle of the
knife also features a safety switch to prevent
accidental discharge and a set of iron sights
to help with aiming.
What could go wrong?
Speaking of which, since the gun part of the
NRS-2 is house inside of the handle, to aim
and fire the NRS-2 you need to point the knife
end towards your own face. While this is looks
unthinkably stupid, firing the NRS-2 in this
fashion isn’t considered overly dangerous
because it has “almost nonexistent recoil“.
On top of this, the NRS-2 has virtually no
muzzle flash and the shot itself is relatively
silent, making it an incredibly covert and
deadly weapon in the right hands.
In terms of range, while exact details are
hard to come by since the NRS-2 is generally
only used by Russian Special Forces and this
information isn’t widely available, it is
said to be deadly from up to 25 metres away.
In the event the user misses with his one
shot, the NRS-2 is also specially weighted
so that it can be used as a throwing knife.
While the NRS-2 has the potential to be an
incredibly deadly weapon in the right hands,
it’s noted that it’s mostly treated as
a curio by most of today’s Spetsnaz troops
who prefer to use the version without a gun
hidden in the handle. This version, known
simply as the NR-2, instead of a gun has a
number of survival implements like matches,
a compass and other goodies an enterprising
soldier may need.
Nevertheless, the NRS-2 continues to stand
as a testament to man’s ingenuity when it
comes to coming up with new ways for killing
one another.
A common misconception about the NRS-2 is
that the weapon actually shoots out the blade
of the knife instead of a bullet. While ballistic
knives are indeed a thing that exist, they
are generally inferior to the NRS-2 due to
the fact they’re only accurate and, perhaps
more importantly, deadly, at a fraction of
the range. While it is rumoured that ballistic
knives were at one point developed for the
Spetsnaz, there’s little proof they ever
used them outside of Tom Clancy novels and
Call of Duty games. Not that they’d need
them anyway considering an integral part of
Spetsnaz training is learning to use throwing
knives. The training is so in depth that even
the standard issue shovel issued to all Russian
soldiers for digging trenches can be used
as an impromptu throwing device in the hands
of a trained Spetsnaz soldier. Spetsnaz troops
are so well trained at throwing objects with
deadly, unerring accuracy that when putting
on a show, you can see them hurling shovels,
knives and even hatchets at targets while
performing such acrobatics as backflipping
through
the air, as depicted above.